foreign
[Music]
Kelly Clarkson adding a little Zing to
her coffee order people didn't expect it
yeah that's the voice coach serenading
an unsuspecting crowd at a Los Angeles
area coffee shop
[Music]
an eyewitness tells E.T she was joined
by five to six singers for about 90
seconds of pure Harmony adding that
Kelly was energetic and enthusiastic
there are no words to describe how
fortunate you feel the customer says
while Kelly was singing music started
playing out of nowhere it felt like a
New York Broadway show there was a huge
shock the impromptu performance comes as
Kelly's talk show makes the big move to
New York City for its next season
they've been on this ride with me behind
the scenes and they get it and the
grammy-winning singers 10th studio album
chemistry drops June 23rd it's rumored
to be inspired by her 2020 divorce from
her ex-husband Brandon Blackstock
divorce is a really
thing among the new 14 tracks her latest
single I hate Love featuring comedian
Steve Martin who's showing off his banjo
skills
sometimes
Mama I'm sorry for using that word but I
only use it when it applies I hate love
as for if Kelly will take her chemistry
album on tour people are saying are you
going on tour here's the thing this is
why I announced the 10 shows in Vegas it
really is like I don't know if y'all
noticed but I have like a nine to fiver
and I also kids we are trying to figure
out
what the possibilities are in certain
parts of our calendar we are trying to
do that
[Music]